hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna work on some more HTML and CSS
we're just gonna continue on with what
we were doing yesterday did make a few
adjustments yesterday mainly in the
JavaScript so I'll briefly go over what
we've done
Harshit helped out a lot with that and
then we'll get right into it probably
gonna be about an hour and a half for
this stream we'll see I actually haven't
been feeling that well so much stomach
hurts really bad I have no idea why so
if it gets like worse than maybe I'll
end the stream but for now I think I'm
okay to stream see we may have I keep
trying to get one of my co-workers to
come in on the stream she's just
starting out with coding and I thought
it would be cool since we're doing
beginner stuff if she would come in and
ask questions too but she said she's too
tired
so we'll see listen if she comes also my
camera keeps stopping so I don't know I
can get it turned back on I'm just gonna
have to keep an eye on it and make sure
that it's it's still glowing
so just to just heads-up if my screen
just freezes like it did just now then I
need to restart it
yeah so all of a sudden my fan will
start going really fast and my camera
shuts off but they don't know why that's
happening all right so let's switch over
to the code and see what's going on here
let me check the lad chat quickly just
to say hello
looks like Oh horseshit wrote a blog
today about graph QL so it's really cool
harsh its blog is HP tech blogs calm so
check that out if you want to read some
of his blogs everybody alright oh cool
Heath it's a great holiday sweater yeah
I actually have two holidays let me show
you all this other holiday sweater I got
should have done it when I had the
camera on full so yeah I'll switch it
back really quickly so we had a white
elephant Christmas gift exchange so at
my my office today and I got this
women's Christmas sweater vest
so I was wearing it around earlier I
have a picture of me with it on on my
Instagram now because it actually fits
me evidently women's size medium is the
perfect size for me oh I think I'll
probably get into my life though let's
see
also I do want to mention since Ethan's
here in the live chat so Ethan did a
stream two days ago just two days ago he
went through a bunch of the new es6
challenges for free code camp and went
through them all solved them wrote the
tests so it was really cool i watched
some of the stream live and i watched
some of the recording of it as well and
you did a great job Ethan so anyway if
you haven't checked that out already I
think it's really cool and it's a good
overview if you would like to contribute
to any of the free code camp challenges
then you know check out that video and
just to get a perspective of how someone
else contributes and then maybe it would
give you a good idea if that's something
you'd like to do andrew says is also
learning graph QL alongside gatsby
intimidating at first but it seems
really powerful yeah definitely though
that was what I thought about it at
first if you're not using graph QL
already check it out we've done some
streams about it you can go back and
watch those will be doing more streams
with graph QL later on but now that I've
used it I don't ever want to use
anything else so if you're using maybe
REST API is right now check out graph qo
it's it's it's worth learning all right
Ethan said thank you so much you're
welcome no problem
all right hey Vern eeks here I do
okay so viniq says hey Jesse hope you
remember me from Nashville in November I
was the one you're helping with the
bookstore project I'm still learning
yeah for sure I remember I was just
wondering recently how you were doing
with the project so I don't know what
yeah I don't remember it's just like out
of nowhere I was like thinking hey did
she ever finish that project but anyway
thanks so much for for coming on and
checking out the stream
all right let's yeah let me get started
okay you're still working on it pretty
cool you'll have to if you can I'd love
to check out the project once it's
finished so I know there was some of the
API your try it in the hit was you could
only access it from a certain place so I
don't know if you if I could see a
working version of it but if it's
possible I that would be kind of cool if
you're up for it okay so let me get
started and let me start my Pomodoro
cycle if you haven't watched before I
kind of break the stream up into several
Pomodoro sessions so we do 25 minutes of
code we take a five-minute break and I
answer some of your questions in the
live chat and we do another 25-minute
session and then after that the whole
second half of the stream is all just
answering questions in the live chat so
be patient if you got some question and
I will get to it at some point during
the stream alright so let me switch back
so you all can see the code so very
quickly let me show you what I've done
and what Harshit is done in terms of
correcting the problem we were having
yesterday so if you remember yesterday
we had the deed let me bring that I
bring over the website so you can see
it's on my other screen now mmm not too
many screens open
so I still trying to find it there we go
okay so yesterday we were having
problems where these were all like
dropdowns right they were hidden by
default you had to click on details to
be on the show so obviously we solved
that problem right it you can see
everything by default so here's how we
did that so
Harshit submitted a pull request
yesterday and went through we make this
a bit bigger I'm gonna hide this on the
side make it bigger and we don't need
this right now so I'm gonna shrink it
and let me know if that's not big enough
for the font size I can make it even
bigger let me get
okay let's someone asked about Angra so
let me give give you that link I think
I'd still have the server on from
yesterday
I never yeah I do so I never turned it
off so here's the link so you can check
out the site live as we're working on it
and if you want let me give you the the
ending so this is where we're at so if
you want to paste that onto the end of
the link that's what page were on the
program I'm using as my editor is Visual
Studio code it's for Microsoft and it is
free let's see
Oh harsh it says that I can remove this
global X content that was for testing
all right cool
thanks yeah I wasn't sure why that was
in there but it worked with it in there
and I've been harsh it's been working
with me on these projects for long
enough that I trust that that was okay
to have in there so anyway I left it in
we'll take it out now so basically it's
just using regular expression here and
then it's replacing it with in this case
a div that's class of details and then a
closing div so I had to change a little
bit so the problem I was having
originally was that there were some
other tags that had the word details in
the tag and it was catching those tags
as well and it was changing it so it has
some really weird things happening with
the HTML so what I did was included the
entire tag so in the opening and closing
brackets and then here I included the
slash as well so I have ec of a to two
different slashes here the first one
tells first one basically means whatever
I type next you know treat it as part
of what I'm looking for you know there's
normally the slash would have a special
meaning and a regular expression but in
this case I actually want to search for
a tag that has that slash in there okay
so the G means global so we're gonna try
to find every instance of that so anyway
that's that's really the only changes I
made from what would heart should had
done and that that works also in our CSS
which will be working mainly in our CSS
now I added this right column blogs and
the BR tag to our list of things not to
display because there was some really
weird positioning things going on
because of these two this was an element
that had a lot of stuff in it but it was
all empty but those things were still
taking up a lot of space and then
there's for some reason WordPress is
inserting a ton of breaks so and so I
figure out how to fix that on the
WordPress side of things I just decided
to display:none for the you know BR tags
all right so that's where we are now
once once I did that with the BR tags
though some things got out of place so
these were all stacked on top of each
other now you can see they're
side-by-side they're definitely better
stacked on top of each other but instead
of adding the the breaks we'll just add
some some CSS to get a position properly
all right so let's go
let's go to our dev tools I'm going to
inspect this and let's move this over to
the side and the first thing we're going
to try to do because I think it'll look
pretty simple and clean is we're just
going to try to get this all to display
properly right in a row and this will be
the way we want it to look on a small
screen so let's say like on a on a phone
screen right so the way we'll probably
do this is we'll start with a small
screen view get it looking good and then
expand and then see what adjustments we
should make for a larger screen I guess
you could call this like mobile first so
that's the way we're gonna do it so
today I'd like to you know get these all
stacked properly and then get the
formatting on this list we need to fix
it a bit that's fonts too small I don't
want it to be bolded so if we can
accomplish that today I'll be happy so
first things first let's get these
stacked on with the title at the top
above the image and then I want these
items phone number email this link to a
CV all stacked so first let's check out
this title and probably the easiest way
to make them stack will be to do a
display block alright so if we do a
display block it's stacked right there
so what I'm going to do then is just
take all of these elements and add
display block to them so when I move
this off to the side now cut so I can
see it and I'm going to go back in here
and let's add a few things in so this is
all just plain CSS
we're gonna add the name name tag
there's a lot of custom HTML tags which
is it's valid to do this but it may look
a little strange and we also need the
phone and email email and let's go CV
link
now there's another tag here that we're
not using right now but some faculty
member profiles might have it so I'm
gonna add it in here and that's a video
embed so just in case we run into that
later on it should be covered by these
rules and the last thing we have is
center column details and that would be
that this education right here that's
the center column details so we'll add
that as well all right so now we're
gonna do a display
display:block and let's save that and
we'll give it a refresh all right cool
so now we have this all stacked up well
that's interesting
I now remember that we did not do
anything to make this responsive at the
top so make sure when we won't forget
that so that that's gonna mess with our
responsiveness a bit here or being able
to test it up properly so I'm gonna just
open this a little bit so we can see
what's going on here and try to get that
fixed
probably the next thing I do is go we'll
be fixing that all right so that's not
bad let's look at our spacing we're
gonna need to add a little bit more
spacing here above education I think we
should add some spacing between the
image and that phone number maybe a
little bit see on this image it doesn't
look bad because there's so much white
at the top but I think on a different
image where there's not so much white
this is going to look cramped so let's
add maybe you know eight pixels of space
here we'll try maybe 16 and that should
be okay for this I do want to check the
font size on this it looks a little
small for me a little smaller than I
like
let's bring this back over so we can
check the font size I guess we have no
font size set so is it automatically
setting I thought I guess is just go
into whatever the default is
so what I'd like to have it's just once
16 pixels all right so we were at 16 I
thought it was 16 16 is not bad but I'd
like to go closer to 18
we'll try 18 on everything if it looks
we'll see how it looks I like to go with
a larger font you know for readability
let's see alright so let's go ahead and
put in here for for the P tags we want
font size to be 18 pixels and that's not
gonna cover everything because we have
some things in in other tags but we'll
add those as we as we find them
now let's let's try to add here under
our title let's let's do it in dev tools
so that you know we can see the result
so let's go with a margin bottom
let's try 8 pixels first and see how
that looks
actually that's not bad it's hard to see
right because of you know the color of
that image
but I think 8/8 works you know what I
think is I'd also maybe like to change
the the font size
I don't know where I here we go so I
already had name here before font size
let's try 26 for that font size and then
we'll go margin-bottom and 8 pixels so
we do try to follow material design and
usually a material design things go in
in like 8 so you see 8 pixels a lot 16
pixels as kind of the spacing between
things so that's what I usually start
out with 8 16 24 I use those values a
lot all right so that's fine for that
one let's try to do a similar spacing
here and this is under a phone so let's
do whoops
accidentally put that on the tag with
with all this in here which it might not
be bad to add some spacing in but I
don't think that much spacing is yeah I
don't know that I would want that much
spacing so here on this tag let's go
with margin top yeah let's go 8 that's
not bad I thought it would be too small
but let's just stick with it for now and
yeah we'll stick with it for now I do
want to make sure we have a proper line
height for everything too so we'll take
care of that in a second so here let's
just take this
and I'm gonna get rid of those font size
and I'm going to change this to phone
all right
you can see right now I have very little
organization to the CSS we may end up
converting this and using it like in the
component at some point or if we do
leave in a CSS mule what kind of truck
we're gonna it better but for right now
it's we don't have a lot so I'm not
super worried about organization that
may not be the best way to do it but
usually I don't worry about that when I
only have a few lines all right so let's
do this center column details and we're
gonna add margin I'm gonna try 16 pixels
yeah 16 is better okay because we really
want to separate that out you know from
from this so 16 looks good and that
heading could maybe be a bit bigger as
well so let's try to do the heading you
know let me because for heading let's
try to make all those those headings
there 20 was the strut 22 pixels
alright I'm gonna see this in comparison
to the title here actually I want the
title to be larger I'm not sure though
that what we've done to the title was
actually taken effect yet so because we
did change that make it a bit bigger
okay but I like that so let's let's
check with that this is center column
details the center column details is
gonna get a margin top of 16 pixels and
then the header heading it's called a
heading right heading is gonna get a
font size of 22 pixels let's double
check to make sure we increased our font
size for name and we did all right so
I'm gonna save that and I'm gonna
refresh it now so we can see all of our
changes okay yeah this is still it's
still not looking as big as I would like
it to be even though we made the font
size 26 so let's go let's go with 30 and
let me make sure okay
I'm not zoomed in alright I'm gonna go
with 30 for this one because I want it
to be obviously you know a bigger than
these subheadings and I think at 30 you
you can get that immediately anything
lower than that and it's not you you
have to kind of look at it more closely
to tell so let's go with 30 and again if
you're just joining me and you haven't
watched the streams before please be
patient if you've written a question in
the live chat I will
to the questions in the live chat in
just a few minutes I split things up and
I do some coding and then I go back to
the live chat so I'm in the coding
session right now and then we'll do some
question-and-answer stuff here
in just a little bit all right so let's
do that I did notice something with the
phone number where I put the wrong thing
so I it should have been margin-top and
I just copied from name and so I got the
wrong wrong thing it there we go okay
much better let's see I want to make
sure our font size change took effect
yes font size 18 but it seems like on
this we're not at font size 18 so let's
add in to our font size 18 let's just
add in new ELLs as well and see if
that'll cover what we want and actually
yeah let's let's try to do it here so it
looked like there wasn't a font size set
at all so we may be able to just cover
everything if we put this on main here
and then the ones that we specified here
should override that let's see if it
works that way okay all right not bad
now this looks right I'm gonna double
check though
okay it's inherited that yeah let's see
if let's see if I took that off okay so
that on main didn't really do much okay
so amazed we'll take that off a main
since it didn't do anything anyway and
it's working on almost everything we
just have these let's see what kind of
tag that is Oh 8 6 that's odd
ok so we're gonna have to override the
default size for an h6
so I usually I don't like to override
the H tags as much if I don't have to
but in this case obviously we can't have
it that small so lets override those h
tags and we can try to be specific and
say H tags that are just within an Li it
probably doesn't matter I'm thinking the
only place where we're gonna see h6 is
on the faculty pages are in here but I
honestly think it will help me reading
this later on to know why exactly I made
that change the eight-six if I specify
here that it was in an Li age 6 and
let's do font size let's make them the
same the same as the headings no we need
them to be smaller than the headings
let's make these
let's let's try 20
okay 20 pixels looks pretty big you know
what I don't mind 20 pixels there so I
don't really even mind 18 but I do want
to take off the the bold
so let's you know what let's play with
the font wait a bit so font late is kind
of like the bonus right of the of the
font so we're going to take it through
some peer 400 is the baseline of what we
have everywhere right now all right
we could go 5
did we have five or six let's try five
right now and let me take this off
yeah it looks like it's six so I don't
want 605 looks much better and we still
have a little distinction there let's
let's check this I want to see I'm gonna
see what would it look like if we change
all these font weights to 300
hmm
I actually really like the look of a
thinner font I'm gonna stake I'm gonna
keep that thinner font now but
definitely want to test this it may not
be as readable on on certain screens so
I'm gonna kind of tentatively keep the
font font weight at 300 all right so
let's add this here as late 300 and then
our eight-six is as font size when we
have it at 20 and then font weight at
OSF 400 yeah okay all right so I'm gonna
save that give it a refresh to see if
anything looks really weird
no but looks fine at least on my monitor
that font still seems really small I
mean I said really 18
it just seems it is really 18 but there
we go all right so ly height 1.5 at
least for me on my screen makes it seem
a lot more readable so let's add that in
as well I usually use the line height of
1.5 so it's not bad we'll stick with
that actually
yeah we'll keep it my night 145 okay now
my Pomodoro timer did go off a minute or
two ago so I'm gonna go a short
five-minute break I'm gonna go back to
the live chat right now and I will
answer as many questions as I can also
just notice that my camera shut off so
I'm gonna get that camera started again
there we go I guess it doesn't really
matter if you all can see me so not a
big deal I'm gonna leave it on this
screen so I can see my timer and I'm
gonna scroll up see what questions I
missed Nino says do you think PHP is a
good language because there's a big gap
in that field and a big opportunity to
make something it my feeling on
programming languages is you can build
good things and terrible things with any
programming language so I personally
don't have as much fun building things
in PHP I enjoy a JavaScript more so
there are certain languages that I
personally like more than others just
because of my experience with it how
good I am with those languages you know
the amount of syntax that it's 8 right
like Python just seems more fun to me
than PHP just because of the syntax
right but it does depend on your
exposure so I would say if you enjoy
using PHP and you can get a job with it
then use PHP I don't really know any of
the statistics as to whether or not jobs
in PHP are growing or shrinking or
anything like that but you might want to
look into that as well if you're trying
to plan out you know what you want to do
for your career and the other good thing
to keep in mind is it's not that hard to
it's from one program a programming
language to another so even if you
decide to specialize in one now you
could always change it up later on you
know if you know if things shift you
know you gotta you know you have to
learn what you need you know for your
job be able to support yourself and your
family and pay the bills
okay harsh it's Irish it says and this
was a little while ago said it's it's
1:30 p.m. there so he's really sleepy
yet or I'm sorry a.m. and yeah hard
if if you if you need to go to sleep by
all means go to sleep I only I just had
to start later today because we had a
Christmas party here at the office so
I'll try to make sure I don't stream
this late usually let's see Harshit
recommends moving the CSS to a style JSX
tag so that it may be scoped and non
render blocking and splitted he'll also
give library loading or should I think I
will move it into a tag like that for
these videos since I wanted to take this
opportunity to do some videos that would
be as easy as possible for beginners to
understand I decided to use the CSS file
but you're completely right we will get
some benefits from moving it into our
component with the style JSX tag so if
if you don't know much about reacting
you can understand we're I was just
talking about don't worry about it
it's it's just the a certain way you
could do something when working with
react so you don't need to worry about
it unless you really want to learn react
let's see Sergio says hello I'm new here
is he doing some kind of free code can't
challenges I'm not doing the challenges
right now in this stream I actually work
on the projects that I need to for my
job as a front-end developer I worked
for a small university and so we're
redoing the main website for our
university and so that's what I'm
working on right now I'm working on a
template that's going to display all the
faculty members here at the University
moisés asks what are those colors on the
number column I'm not sure I'm not
exactly sure what you're asking like
what number column you're asking about
so if you can if you're still watching
could you give me some hints as to what
number column you're talking about I'm
sure if I would have saw your comment
while I was doing it it would have been
obvious but now after the fact I can't
remember what I was doing that would
have a number column
so anyway I'd love to answer your
question just need a little bit more
info if possible please okay so I'm
gonna go back to the coding for a bit
and then I'll come back in the lab chest
if I didn't get to your question yet
stick around for a little while if you
can and I will get to your question if
for some reason you can't stick around
I'll still answer your question later on
and you can always watch the recording
of this video and hear the answer to
your question you know whatever time you
feel like watching the recording okay so
let's start this up we'll do one more
Pomodoro session okay I think we're good
I do need to make sure that I'm home in
time to watch the baby so my wife is and
most of my kids are gonna go Christmas
caroling at a nursing home but my
youngest Cordelia is one and a half
almost she was sick last night so
obviously we don't want her go in a
nursing home she liked it you know the
people they're sick so I'm gonna stay
home with her but that means I have to
make sure I'm home from work and enough
time for them to get over to the nursing
home all right so let's see what we want
to do now all right so we have
everything in a column the spacing is
not bad it's not
perfect see what we can do about it all
right it looks like we need less spacing
between education and this first bullet
point we need to make education as a
header and these we need to make them
the same it looks like something's off
in here so maybe it's I think it's the
weight so we'll have to match the font
weight so I think this is 400 and this
looks like 300 so let's match this font
weights and then let's change the yeah
it's gonna be slight but I definitely
think there's less spacing here so we're
gonna change that up a bit and then
we'll move on and we'll work on the
spacing down here okay so first things
first
let's see what sag this is so this is a
heading heading tag and I think if we
put weight yep that should do it for the
front weight and then let's do a margin
bottom let's let's see where we're at
let's do a zero first all right so we
don't really have yeah we have nothing
there right now what's giving us that
space there we go
it's it's inside of a paragraph tag
that's a problem let's see what we can
do where is this paragraph tag you know
what we probably don't even originally
have a paragraph tag it's just WordPress
is adding this in here for us hmm all
right we can we can select just this
paragraph tag and let's do that here
just to test it out and let's go with a
margin whoops
bottom of zero that didn't even move it
up that it now it's making no difference
interesting
that's really odd okay well I guess we
won't worry about that let's take this
off there now and well in this case I
think we're just gonna have to do a
negative margin if we can here
so let's find oh yeah
so we got to get inside this P tag again
and let's find this let's go with the
center call on details and let's add our
margin on since this so let's go margin
whoops
margin bottom of let's go with a
negative 8 pixels and now I'm gonna have
to I'm gonna eyeball this a bit for now
if we can get it close on me all right
with that
that looks pretty close I'm gonna leave
it at that for now because that's yeah
that's really really close okay so we're
gonna add a margin bottom of 8 to our
center column details and then we're
also gonna add that where was that
heading we're gonna add that font size
I'm sorry font weight 400 all right
wonderful all right now let's go down
hey did that not work
that's inspected
all right it's being overridden which is
okay so let's go in here and just make
it a bit more specific so I'm just gonna
put this inside of the pea for now I
know that will work hmm it's shit'll
words
oops I added pixels on the end all right
so if I may not even need this now it's
supposed to just be 400 not 400 pixels
that's my problem all right
great that works okay let's check out
the spacing here I'm most worried about
the space between these this should be a
lot closer since this description goes
with this heading here
so let's find our h6 and we're gonna
want to remove most of that bottom
margin so we can see we have a forty six
point six pixels down here so it's the
margin is probably a.m. yeah so we have
an en value let's try to make it let's
just go right here with our margin
bottom let's give it a texels oh I like
that
yeah I like that a lot okay and actually
let's go with the margin top Oh 16
pixels yeah much better much better
hmm you know what I may even want to
let's increase this to 24 and let's bump
this down
all right so something else is messing
it up its it should be alright let's
figure out what else is messing this up
okay so on these P tags we also have a
margin at the top here which
in this case I think a negative margin
is going to be the easiest way for us to
go instead of trying to select these P
tags and not affect some of the other
ones so let's go back on that h6 and
let's go with a margin bottom and let's
take it negative
twelve looks not bad yeah it's not bad
on these headings I'd like to have a
little bit more space though above each
one all right so let's first put this in
see see you can see the value now
especially if you're just starting out
the value of using dev tools of being
able to immediately just kind of adjust
your changes and then you can just copy
and paste them right over into here
you know just quickly hit save and then
a refresh on your browser just to double
check that everything works and there
you know just kind of line by line you
can test your your styles and you know
we've kind of made quick work of this
page and cleaned it up quite a bit and
we have like a really nice site feedback
loop you know like immediately we can
see the changes so it can at least for
me you know really help save a lot of
time you know but you do things like
this okay I want to now add a margin on
the top of these headings
oh sorry yawn okay
a merchant top
sixteen that's not working
why is it not working all right so let's
let's go up a bit here to these right
column details and let's add it on right
column details with margin top 16 pixels
hmm that's not working either
hmm all right let's add it to the bottom
then see if we can make it work on the
bottom
is
all right this is odd I'm not able to
change the margins and padding here why
can I not do that
I know I've run into things like this
before
and I can't really remember oops
you know what maybe that's why I chose
the wrong wrong thing okay let's try
this again we want center column details
so let's go with center column details
margin bottom let's go 16 pixels there
we go that's what we want
let's try 24 24 texels okay much better
I just wanted to make it more apparent
that these headings go with the what's
below it and not with you know what's
above so we have it has messed up this
spacing won't mess up the spacing
hmm
all right well I like I like this look
I'm gonna keep this look
all right so this does look oh that's
why so this was in a center column
details as well hmm
Oh so we already we already had a center
column details that we were using and we
just overrode that okay
alright let's take this out let's change
this
24 let's see what this looks like
okay not bad could use a bit more here
you know why because this is actually
this is right calling details okay all
right this is what we were running into
before where we just had some weird
things going on here
all right let's see if we can do
there we go all right so we had set
everything else to display:block but not
right column details so let's add that
to our display block so that's what we
needed to be able to make this this
margin work so we're going to do that
and then we're gonna add under right
column details this margin top of 24
you'll save that and refresh rates
alright everything looks how we wanted
it to look
not bad
yeah not bad a lot better than what we
started with let me check my time here
about seven minutes
okay so that's Oh
my camera went off again so let me set
reset my camera okay cameras reset and
think about this
let's do I'm gonna try something with
the positioning of this this container
so this test ID content should be the
container for all of our content in here
so I'd like to make a max width
[Music]
there we go
all rights that will bring this in a bed
and let's try to do the center should we
let's go with let's do some media
queries here alright so with this the
default is going to be max width and
we're gonna say 90% and then we're gonna
give it a margin of zero Auto which you
can use to Center something that is not
everything will Center like this but for
sure if it's set to display block you
can Center it like this it also has to
have a width all right so we're gonna do
that but then let's add this media query
so let's go media screen and let's go
men with I'm gonna have to look at the
syntax for this I haven't written a
media query by hand in a long time
area okay it is - men with and we're
gonna say let's just do 600 pixels for
now as I made with and then now we're
gonna say we want the max width to be
let's say 70% oops forgot to put in the
hey let's just copy this
so I'm
a bit spoiled by SAS not having it right
as much what did I say I wanted that to
be 70 yeah let's try 70% for that so I'm
gonna save that and refresh okay
great so it should be 70% of the screen
within this case which so you can see
it's only taking up 70% but as we get
down to lower than 600 pixels it changes
and now it's taking up 90% of the screen
width right because on a smaller device
you know we want to be able to show
everything we're not as worried about
you know screen real estate there so
that's that's what I wanted I mean
there's definitely room for adjusting
that but that just roughly gives it you
know kind of a better look you know more
of a look that we were that were used to
and so let me explain that media query
so if you are I've advertised this
stream as being a very good stream for
beginners so let me change or let me go
through what's what's happened here
because this is if you're just starting
out a media query is kind of a somewhat
tricky thing to deal with so here's what
I've done I've made the default so this
simply selects a div that has the
attribute the data test ID attribute of
content okay because we happen to have a
div like that so we've selected that div
and this would be you know very similar
to selecting a div that has a class of
content right we've just kind of made up
our own attribute there so by default
the max width is 90 okay and as I said
the 0 margin:0 auto Centers it so the
default size is actually the mobile size
right once we get the screen bigger once
it gets to 600 pixels right so if
so basically this is saying the minimum
width of the screen that anything within
this query will work on is 600 pixels so
anything below 600 pixels this will be
ignored if you're above 600 pixels this
will be run it's below this so it will
use the cascading nature of cascading
style sheets CSS and it will go with
whatever value this has overriding this
value so that's why we didn't have to
add margin:0 auto again all right that's
not overwritten here just this one so
once the screen gets 600 pixels it
switches over all right there's 600
pixels or more it switches over to max
with 70% and we could put anything we
wanted in here we could make the text
size go to 300 if we wanted to on a big
screen we could make the background
color go green if we wanted to really
anything you can reposition elements you
know anything that you can do with CSS
you can put inside a media query if you
wanted to go the other way around and
have this be the base value for a large
screen and have whatever's inside a
media query only apply on a small screen
you just switch it and do max width
instead of men with and then with max
width what would happen is anything
that's above 600 pixels won't have any
of this stuff applied to it but if it's
below 600 pixels then anything in here
will be applied right so these I know
we're really tricky for me starting out
with HTML and CSS it took me a long time
to get comfortable enough to kind of
write my own at first I always just
copied and pasted ones that I know
worked from other projects and would
just kind of adapt those ones you know
even now I had to look up the syntax so
I got to about here and had to double
make sure I was doing it right so I've
been doing this for years and I still
have to look up the syntax oh don't feel
bad about that
but it can be tricky trying to figure
out well should I put min or should I
put max so it usually takes a lot of
practice before you can just remember it
and even I get confused about it still
but anyway that's basically how media
queries work they don't have to be with
based you could set a height sometimes
that type of thing helps if you're
trying to target like a landscape view
on a phone or something like that you
can set a width or height right because
some big phones have much larger
dimensions than you would normally think
so it's it's helpful you can target a
lot of other things right so you can
actually target orientation so landscape
or portrait for a phone you can target
aspect ratio I don't really know all the
things that you can you can target you
can make a media query just for print so
it'll only work when the user goes to
hit print and then you can have print
only styles be applied so anyway a lot
of cool stuff you can do with that but
the most common use I've ever seen for
these are for width for responsive
layouts so when you hear people talk
about responsive websites most of the
responsiveness comes from these media
queries okay there are some things you
can do with JavaScript that can also
help and some things you can do with
setting like percentage widths on items
that's very important but you know the
magic happens in the media queries okay
I went over my time for coding and kind
of talked a little bit but I know that
was really tricky for me so I want to
make sure I got a good explanation of
that and for all of you hopefully that
made sense all right so now we've gone
through poo to Pomodoro cycles we've
accomplished everything that we wanted
to and a little bit more which is great
I don't think I messed up anything today
which is a very rare occurrence so I'm
happy
and my stomach quit hurting and I feel
fine now so all I know this was a really
amazing stream today so I'm gonna scroll
back up to where I left off in the live
chat and I'm gonna go answer all your
questions so if you have a question you
have it put it in the chat yet please do
so now you can also ask me questions on
Twitter if you like my link to my
Twitter account is in the description
below this video you can ask questions
in the comments to the video I'm on all
the different social media things so get
in touch with me whatever way is most
comfortable with you I'd be happy to
answer your questions look at some code
for you I can't guarantee that I can
answer it right away
but I'll try to get to it as soon as I
can alright one benefit of asking the
question in the live chat is you not
only get my answer which may or may not
even be a good answer but you also get
the expertise of all the other very
talented knowledgeable people that are
in the live chat right now so I do
recommend that as the number one way to
ask a question right okay so I did leave
off with a question about what are the
colors on the number column I'm still
not sure what that was referring to so
hopefully Moises I'm hopefully I'm
pronouncing that right hopefully Moises
has clarified later on down in the live
chat and we'll see that in a minute
so move on here John Hanson as a comment
says Jessie you stated about trusting
pixel size and it is absolute though
it's a good idea to let others know that
REM Andi M is often a better choice when
it comes to responsive design okay yeah
that's a really good point yeah let's
let me
GSS I'm just double-checking to make
sure I'm getting all everything in the
conversation here about REM and EMS okay
so let me address that I do see a lot of
people use REM or a.m. the reason I
don't use REM REM is because I just
don't know enough about them to use them
comfortably so I really I have nothing
against using them but I know what I do
with pixels will work because I've used
it before I'm open to learning more
about using Iain instead of pixels as a
unit and if that is generally the better
way to do things then you know I'll try
to learn it then I'll try to use that
from now on but at least for this dream
I was definitely not comfortable using
that so I guess that's but that's a good
disclaimer on this so if you're watching
and you're used to using REM REM don't
switch up the pixels just because you
saw me do it I this may not be the best
way to do it it is a way to do it and it
works but there may be a better way so
and I think that can go for everything
that we do on this stream as well I'm
definitely just showing one way to do
things and that's the way I know how to
do it and I'm always trying to learn
better ways to do it so if if you think
you know a better way to do something
please let me know I can't guarantee you
and I'll start doing it right away
because I'll have to learn how to do it
first but I'll definitely take it into
consideration and try to use it and if
you ever want to submit a pull request
to limit projects and use a technique
that you think is better
feel free don't feel like you have to
match what I'm doing all the time I'll
review the pull request I'll check it
out I might ask you some questions so
that I can understand it better and I
may end up using your technique in in
all my future projects so that certainly
happened before with people contributing
pull requests and it just blows my mind
and I change the way I do things
so anyway John Hanson thank you for
bringing that up and yeah I wish I could
say more about the difference but I
they said I'm just not knowledgeable I
know you John and a few others have
brought that up in past dreams and so I
think maybe it's time that I better do a
little bit of research on that
nobody says Jesse I think justifying
your paragraph would also be better
let's check that out yeah maybe we can
yeah maybe we can try that out I'm not
gonna try it right now on the stream but
maybe we have to try that out we'll try
it later on or maybe on another stream
also I want you all that are watching
let me know what you think about these
streams that kind of go over more basics
because a lot of the streams late they
had been going over more advanced things
which is fun and challenging but I have
noticed that I'm getting a lot of
response and a lot of different people
watching when I do these beginner type
streams so if if you all think that this
is beneficial let me know I'll try to
work in some beginner stuff you know
maybe at least like once a week if I can
I may not always be able to do it
depending on what I'm working on but I
you know I'd love to be able to you know
have these streams be accessible to to a
wider audience
so let me know what you all think about
it
okay John Hanson says REM is a relative
base that can be set even with media
with at different sizes
eeehm is set as EMS set will then change
the pixel sizes with the width changes
okay that's interesting so basically we
could get like a responsive font size
with em let me know if that's what
you're saying John if I have that right
I think that's what you're saying and
that actually seems really cool so the
idea then would be the font size would
actually get bigger or smaller depending
on our screen size which I really like
that I love that idea so yeah let me
know if I if I'm understanding that
correctly please Youssef says hey I'm a
newbie here and newbie decoding so do
you think view is a good option to start
learning a framework for jazz I haven't
used view myself but I've heard a lot of
good things about it there's a people
that you know that work as developers
that I I respect their work and they use
you so I'd say it's probably fine to
start out with but I would I would
caution try to learn some of the basics
of JavaScript before you go right into
the framework now I'm gonna put a big
disclaimer on that right if you need to
do projects and get work done so that
you can support your family and pay the
bills use whatever you can use right I
totally understand that so if you know
you can get a job or clients right now
and you need to use view do it but just
while you're doing it remember to keep
up you know your studies on normal
JavaScript because that's gonna set you
up to succeed later on when let's say
nobody uses view anymore you know the
years down the road well if all you knew
was view and you never took the time to
learn basic vanilla JavaScript then it
might be a lot harder for you to switch
to whatever the new
work is that people are using so if you
have time and you're learning try out
some regular JavaScript first before you
go into a framework whatever that
framework is which view is a good one
but if you got to jump into stuff and
use view there's nothing wrong with that
just be aware that you take a little bit
of time to learn you know some of the
basics so I'm open to other opinions on
that as well I know I've heard people
have strong opinions before about making
sure you learn vanilla JavaScript and
they said assuming you have all the time
in the world to just study yeah that's
probably a good way to do things
but realistically most people don't have
that luxury so I'm not gonna you know
say hey you got to do it like this and
make everyone feel bad for not being
able to do that so I say try to do it
the best way you possibly can within
reason you know take into account your
situation
let's see oh goodness no beer said it
was it was 240 a.m. where he's at and
that was that was a while ago so it's
probably after 3 a.m. now thanks for
staying up so late no beer please feel
free to go to sleep if you're still
awake you can always just catch the end
of the stream on the you know the
recording John Hanson has a quick react
question which is better
Axios or fetch for in a simple post to a
PHP mailer I have very limited
experience with Axios I've seen it in
use I can't remember if I've ever
actually used it myself but I am a big
proponent of using fetch because it's
well depending on the browser it's
supported its built-in it's going to be
more lightweight for you
Axios is another library you know that
you have to learn more things you have
to bring in I don't know how heavy
Axios is really so it could be super
lightweight it's not an issue but I've
always gone with fetch so but like I
said I don't know enough about access to
really get into pro's and con's
other than I figured it's it's always
better to just use you know whatever the
base thing is you know for the browser
which in this case is fetch not for
every version of every browser but going
forward that's I think that's gonna be
what's what's used so it may as well
just use it now unless there's some
feature and Axios that that you really
really need or like let's see wriggle
says in all honesty I like PHP and Ruby
and whatnot over JavaScript JavaScript
just seems to do some really silly stuff
by comparison and you have to
second-guess it a lot in my opinion hey
that's totally valid let me see rego are
you the one that asked earlier maybe not
somebody had asked earlier about
whether to learn PHP or something like
that and I think I had mentioned you
know it really kind of depends on what
you like using so the bottom line is
there are jobs out there for PHP
developers I mean think of all those
WordPress sites out there right as long
as WordPress is out there there's always
going to be jobs for PHP developers and
then like Ruby there's a lot of ruby
sites out there there's work for people
in almost every language so find what
you really love to do and do it if you
don't really have a preference then
maybe you want to look more into well
what what companies do I like to work
for what did they use things like that
but I mean that's just the way it's
gonna be yeah some people like chocolate
ice cream some people like vanilla
some people like strawberry it you know
it's it's only natural that the same
thing is gonna happen with programming
languages you know I like JavaScript I
don't really care that much for PHP but
I use it when I have to I don't hate it
I just like JavaScript better I don't
think there's any programming language
that I hate you know they're just I like
JavaScript better because I've had the
most experience with JavaScript it makes
sense to me all right so you know when
regul is saying hear it javascript seems
to do some really silly stuff by
comparison
it doesn't seem silly to me because I'm
used to it right so it just all kind of
depends on what you're used to doing so
there's nothing wrong with you know
coding in whatever language you want it
I said as long as as long as you're cool
with it and you can do good things with
that then you'll go for it
good girl Sammy says can you learn
coding at 21 years old yeah you can for
sure I don't know if if you're asking if
21 is too old or too young to learn to
code but I would say 21 is
of fine days to learn how to code I
didn't really start getting into coding
you know seriously at full time until I
was 20 in my late 20s I can't remember
how what I was exactly so I was in our
late 20s so and I'm an okay code or now
you all can judge for yourself because
I've done enough live streams that I'm
not even gonna attempt to rank myself as
a coder it's it's there for everybody to
see
but yeah so if you want to learn coding
and you're 21 go for it
Sergio said no you're too old most
people start cutting at 10 I'm assuming
that that's a joke it's being sarcastic
from sir yeah her should said but I like
Axios API more yeah in that case if you
really like Axios use Axios right if
Axios works you know stick with it
Brook says I'm 26 started less than a
year ago Jordan asked if I was doing
this in WordPress the data is coming
from WordPress so I'm running what's
called a headless installation of
WordPress so I'm not using any of like
the the themes right or the templates
for things I'm just using it to be an
admin interface for people to store data
and on my sequel database and then I'm
using the WP graph QL plug-in to be able
to use graph QL to pull the data out and
into our react project so what we were
just working in is actually react but we
were just pulling in a bunch of HTML and
so we're doing it we're using just basic
CSS and not really a more react style of
doing CSS just because of the unique
situation that we're in with this data
so at some point we'd like to convert it
all over so we can do it you know a
little bit more properly according to
the you know best practices with react
but right now you know we need we just
need to make sure that we get it looking
good for launch day and so that's first
priority you know the other stuff will
get pushed back and can get taken care
of after launch
see
good girl Sammy is I'm just gonna follow
this conversation a bit because I think
it'll be helpful to newer people so good
girl Sammy says rook how long did it
take you to learn it less than a year
because Rick had said was a wreck
started last year it's a hard should ask
if good girl Sammy was starting from
scratch John Hanson says I just started
html/css a long time I started just HTML
and CSS a long time ago but jQuery PHP
JavaScript react at the age of 60 never
too old
I like that thanks for sharing that John
I see a hard caught that I was
trying to use pixels on font weight
thank you harsh it I didn't see it in
the live chat but I appreciate you
putting it in there
okay so good girl Sammy is starting from
scratch but hassle has a lot of ideas I
just got to learn to code
Leonardo Leonardo says what's up how you
doing how y'all doing today I'm doing
pretty pretty low now so I was how you
doing thanks for watching all right so
poison said I'm glad other people
problems was styling I always thought I
was the exception well I don't know
about everybody else but I definitely
have problems with styling sometimes I
actually really love CSS I know I've
heard some developers that are
specialized in JavaScript say they don't
like CSS but I still like it
I really like it it's just so easy to
make things happen on the screen you
know very quickly but it is tricky
it's very tricky sometimes Steven says
Jessie going old-school with straight
CSS today yeah definitely
good girl Sammy says I got a question
for you if if you get a nice idea for
project should you go to a company or
should you try to build it yourself my
answer to that would just be it depends
on if you think you have the skills to
be able to build it yourself so if if
you can then why not build it yourself
it might be fun you might learn a lot in
the process if it's a big idea where you
think you know you're definitely going
to need help with it or you know maybe a
lot of funding then you might want to go
to a company but don't really take my
word for it I don't have a lot of
experience at doing things like that you
know sometimes I have ideas and I use
them I figure out a way to use them in
my
my day-to-day work so I can work on it I
don't really have experience with going
to a company in proposing my ideas
john hanson asks when the production
build is deployed to the server why is
it that so many things keep the site
alive in in cash especially when
updating the files is there an easier
way around this john are you asking in
general or in particular to the sites
that we've been doing on the stream in
general I know there's there can
sometimes be a caching problem for
instance like a CSS file might be cached
in a user's browser and you can't do
anything about it unless you change the
name of the CSS file so there are some
things you can get that can
automatically change the name every time
you update your CSS file and then you
push it changes the references some of
my projects the earlier projects were
set up with gulp and we had it set up to
automatically change the references to
the files in the production build and
change the name of the CSS so that's one
way to get rid of it but otherwise you
know all your caching options can
definitely be changed if you have
caching going on in a server you know
you can you can set all that yourself
even if you're using a content delivery
network like CloudFlare or something you
can still go in and manually flush the
cache so I guess depending on how you
set things up you know it can make it
harder or easier to get rid of the cache
if you make updates but there's always a
way to to make that happen
rook says that shows a lot of fighting
the markup you have to do there Jessie
how excited are you about everything
eventually being in the right spot in
the database I'm really excited I'm
trying not to think about it too much
because I know that day is is months
away so I resigned myself to the fact
that I'm gonna have to fight with the
markup for a little while but I'm I'm
convinced that that is going to be the
easier the faster route and we need
speed for this project right now so the
cool thing is going to be to that when
the site comes out it's definitely going
to be an obvious improvement over what
the current site is so people are gonna
like it it's gonna load a lot faster
it's going to be more clean people are
like it but then a month or two after
once we get the date all sorted out we
can actually make you know what we have
going on now even better
so it's almost I think gonna be a good
thing because users are gonna see this
big change and it's going to be so much
better and then not that long after that
they're gonna see these tiny little
changes in the different parts of the
site as we get the data sorted properly
and when we do that we pull it in to our
react components we're gonna style it a
bit differently we're going to do it
exactly as we would have done it if we
had the freedom right now to do it that
way all the freedom of the markup so I
think it'll be cool for people to see
how actively you were keeping up with
the site not everybody's gonna notice
that but some people will and I think
they'll appreciate that we might never
know about it or hear any compliments
about that but I I think it'll be it'll
be fun
it's
okay Harshit is responding to John
Hanson's question about caching and it's
talking about that there's a way with
webpack to automat automatically change
filenames so yes that's pretty much what
I was doing before with golf but you can
also do it with lead pack
hey Clint C's is a Quincy Larson was in
the the chat not sure if he's still here
but he was here at one point if you
don't know who Quincy is he is the the
founder and head of free code camp
so without Quincy none of this would
would be going on it's always a pleasure
when Quincy gets to check out some of
the the live stream so I remember when
free code can't first started up just
thinking like what an awesome guy Quincy
was for starting this so I'm still a
little bit starstruck whenever Quincy's
in the in the live chat
Rago says you fix the bugs in your
stomach yeah for sure
honestly you know what I think it was I
most you probably don't care about my
health problems but I enjoy getting
water today I had a double espresso and
then I had at the Christmas party some
old wine and a root beer and I ate a
bunch of food and cookies and I think
that was just what killed my stomach so
before the stream I drank some water and
once that got through my system I think
that's what would help maybe I was a bit
dehydrated and had too much sugar so I
feel like my kids when I tell them like
you know don't have too much sugar
you'll get a bellyache well that's
actually true it happened to me today
let's see poisoned ass how often are
these live streams I I do try to do them
every day Monday through Friday sometime
around 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
give or take an hour or two I don't
always do them five days a week though
frequently I end up having meetings or I
might take a day off and I can't really
stream from my house because the the
internet connection is not fast enough
there so anyway ideally my goal is five
days a week so that's what I try for but
usually it's less than that Samson says
I've missed a lot in the past few days
but luckily I am back I'll be following
the streams awesome glad to have you
back Samson alright Quincey says great
practical advice thanks Khaleesi I
really appreciate that all right very
sorry if i mispronounce this name i'm
gonna try my best
let me know how its supposed to be
pronounced if i mess it up so it looks
like it y'all
John all right so it looks like it's ily
o SJ o n I'm not sure how to pronounce
that so apologies for that please let me
know how that's supposed to be
pronounced anyway they say hey there
Jessie you've given the best advice
right now thanks I really appreciate
that
thanks I tried my best I don't think I'm
always right I might not be right even
most of the time but I'd try to do the
best I can
oh okay so so john hanson saying you set
rem on a div sorry where we skip back to
the conversation about pixels versus REM
versus am so so like on a container div
like the HTML or the body
you set the REM then using media queries
you set you you set wits with PM and
then they'll change relative to the
width of the screen and he says it works
great okay like i said i'm gonna have to
do like test that out of it maybe i'll
go through a tutorial or something and
maybe we can try it out when we do we're
gonna have to do a lot of different
templates for different types of pages
so maybe on the next template we do
hopefully i can learn enough about it
that we can use it then that might be
fun to try to do and then compare and
then you all can see what it's like to
do one or the other and how hard it was
to implement one or the other and then
what the results look like
okay so ARS why is synchronous functions
bad practice or in industry practice
all right let's I'm gonna see if someone
else answered that first I don't say the
same thing
okay so AR I'm gonna do my best to
answer this question I'm gonna say right
now I don't know if I'll do a good job
here as some of this up somewhat
confused about the question because of
that that second comment so what I'm
thinking is the question is really why
are synchronous functions industry
practice well in in regard to JavaScript
at least we think I'm gonna mess this I
don't mess this up at this point I'm
wondering if I should just say I don't
know enough or I should try to give this
question a shot how about this if you're
still watching could you clarify your
question just a bit because I'm not sure
if you're asking why is synchronous
functions in industry practice or why or
synchronous functions a bad practice so
let me know that and then maybe I'll try
to answer that
Rago says for the record I'm 28 and have
been doing web dev stuff since I was 16
that's awesome yeah you've had a nice
round of it so far
I'm gonna try to say this name late Elif
race
hey I'm not sure it's la I tal Afra ISE
if you let me know what the best way to
pronounce that is I'll be sure to
pronounce it correctly for now on anyway
they say yes please do more beginner
streams awesome I'll keep that in mind
so once again please let me know in the
chat or in some other way whether or not
you like these type of beginner style
streams if you'd like to see more of
them or just you know general kind of
advice on on that kind of thing
particularly about what what I can do to
help out beginners Renko says CSS is
love CSS is life I remember when I was
first learning HTML I'd style my pages
using tables oh yeah I remember that I
remember when I first learned HTML
actually I learned HTML in CSS long
before I actually started doing real web
dev stuff so back in I don't know like
the early 2000s tables were kind of what
I learned with I'm glad to be moved on
from there I still occasionally have to
work on some old site that uses tables
and everything always like what can you
make this responsive and as soon as I
see its tables I'm like sounds kind of a
pain
veronique says yes too much sugar Jesse
now you have my stomach hurting that was
I feel so silly that is like I ate too
much sugar and I didn't drink any water
like I'm a grown person like I should
know better than that
Oh harsh it has some answers about those
synchronous functions so harsh it's
asynchronous functions actually block
the code execution which slows down the
application and an async function
everything is fired simultaneously so
execution is faster so that's kind of a
good break down between the two I'm
still kind of looking for a little bit
more explanation and the first question
that a are asked but even if we don't
get that Harshit thank you for for
clarifying that
a harsh it says Jesse I have a question
how easy is it for me to get a job
considering my current skill set
honestly hard I think you have
great skills you've been such a help and
all of these projects that we've been
working on if I can hire you to do
back-end stuff here at the University
I'd hire you right now so I think you've
got a great shot at getting a job you
have a good portfolio you have a lot of
pool requests that have been accepted
for these projects so you have a lot to
show that you know what you're doing so
I mean I know you're young you're only
16 so that's probably going to be an
issue depending on what country you're
trying to get a job in but that's really
the only issue that I could see you know
that I'm not sure about is just simply
the age thing I mean I know like in the
United States you can definitely work at
16 it's fine but would a company be
comfortable hiring someone who's 16 for
like a full time job probably not at
least not here in the United States so
but I I think potentially freelance
might be a better
out for you to go or even better yet
because because of your okay I should
saying I'm not getting a job now I'm at
school okay so assuming that you're out
of school later on you're older I don't
think with your current skill set and
assuming that you're going to improve
your skills as well which I'm sure you
will I think that you'll have a great
time getting a job you'll have an easy
time finding a job so I think the key
thing will be just making sure that you
get your work out there to companies to
see because if they can see it I think
they'll be impressed I'm always
impressed with the work that you do so
yeah when you get out of school make
sure you let me know and if there's any
way that I can hire you for something I
probably will I don't know if I'll be in
a position to do that but if I'm in a
position to give you a recommendation or
something I definitely do it so anyway
just keep adding on to your portfolio
you know keep doing what you're doing
with contributing to open source
projects you know it seems like you're
already doing all the things that people
say will help you get a job so I would
say just keep on with what you're doing
and like I said I think it won't be that
hard and when it comes time for looking
for a job let me know I'd be happy to
help you out you know check out your
resume and stuff and give you some
advice I've been on both sides of things
I've been the person getting interviewed
and I've been the person doing
interviews for developer jobs so that's
not a bad perspective to have you know
being on both sides of that so you know
I'd be happy to give you insight into
that when the time comes
let's see the hopeless Brit says our
website design teacher made us use
frames / iframes or something along
those lines to layout our sites this is
back in 2015
Wow I was with you until you said 2015
so I remember learning frames also in
the early 2000s with tables 2015 I will
say this normally like web design
courses at the high school and college
level are usually behind the times when
it comes to the latest stuffs yeah so if
I were doing a site now I would
definitely not use frames I would not
use iframes for the layout but it was
done like that at one point all right so
I'm there to add some more info about
this synchronous asynchronous function
thing so Umberto's says each type has
their own uses it depends on whether the
function calls are dependent on each
other and some if not in most cases you
do not need calls to be fully executed
before the rest of the code runs so you
would want a sync calls for all of them
to run at the same time you would want
to use synchronous calls though to make
sure that one function runs completely
before the next that makes sense
umberto says I presume async would be
industry standard because most function
calls can't be run simultaneously
alright that's that's a great answer is
very informative thanks Umberto
Christian says hello I've been following
your livestream since August and I'm
learning a lot specifically on react Jas
your videos are some of my go-to
resources awesome thank you so much for
saying that Christian I'm going to say I
got a comment a really positive comment
on Twitter earlier and I always get
positive communists in the live chat I
just want to say I really really
appreciate it when you all have comments
like that I certainly don't mind
criticism too you know I always I'm
trying to get better so criticism is
fine but really positive comments like
that helped me to keep going you know
they when I see stuff like that it's
like I think you know what youyou are
really helping people you got to keep
going this stream and it keeps me going
I really appreciate it
so so thank you Christian and thank you
everyone who's given me a lot of
positive encouragement really really
appreciate it
alright so that French sounding name
that I couldn't pronounce actually means
strawberry milk in French so I guess let
me know how to pronounce that in French
otherwise is it cool if I just call you
strawberry milk
cuz that's easier for me to say but I'd
be happy to pronounce it properly if I
can figure it out Carlos says I've moved
away for a few years from web
development I'd like to know how to
upgrade myself and learn the current
tools Carlos I just say check out it
depends on how you like to learn if
you're if you like videos there's a ton
of stuff on YouTube just make sure with
videos you're watching or fairly new
check out some stuff on what's called
es6 or es 2015 for some of the latest
JavaScript stuff you can go beyond it
and even check out es 7/8 you know all
that stuff but at least X es6 for some
of the newer
things that are happening in JavaScript
if you want to check out some of the
newer frameworks you know check out
react check out view those who that
would be my advice now I'm not exactly
sure where you moved away and what you
are working on in terms of web
development so I guess that will kind of
depend on that but I guess it shouldn't
be too hard to get back in like I said
depending on what you were doing before
I personally kind of think that videos
might be the best way to go with that
just to kind of see what other people
were doing but there's certainly a ton
of blog posts out there that can help
you out as well the hopeless sprit says
yeah it was a shame at the time none of
us knew any better about frames and
iframes looking back I shouldn't have
just trusted our teachers and going
along with it yeah that's a really tough
thing you know like you want to trust
your teachers know what they're doing
but there's really not a whole lot of
incentive especially at the university
level for professors to keep up to date
right if a professor has tenure you know
they really can't get fired unless they
do something crazy so you know they have
to keep up with all the meetings and
paperwork and grading where's the
incentive for them to really stay up to
date because you can only really stay up
to date on things if you're actually
working on projects you know they don't
have time to do that so it's it's much
easier for them to keep going with
they've been doing right they don't want
to have to redo all their lesson plans
and stuff every single semester to stay
up to date right or even like what's the
current best practice at the beginning
of the semester might change by the end
of the semester you know this field
changes way too fast for the current you
know way that colleges are set up to
keep up so here at this university at
Franciscan University I'm trying to work
with the computer science department to
find a solution to that so I have done a
guest lecture and we I'm hopefully going
to maybe team teach a course so that the
computer science professor can
a lot of the basic the testing grading
paperwork and a lot of the basics that
don't change if web development and then
I can come in and my part will be to get
the students up-to-date on stuff I'm
working on and what the latest is in the
industry I think something like that
where you have a collaboration with
someone that's actually in the industry
working would be the ideal situation for
computer science students at the
university level so anyway I totally
understand where you're coming from I
actually dropped Mike in web development
course in college because of that very
issue I'm have to wrap things up soon my
wife's texting me asking me where I am
I'm going to need to go home soon so
anyway that's kind of a tough thing you
learn a lot of good things in a computer
science program but you often don't
learn a lot of new cutting-edge things
all right
Harshit says Jessie what happened to the
electron project you didn't even create
the repo I thought I did create the repo
where'd it go
let's check it out
hmm
did I never push that to get up check
out a few some work on
oh I'm sorry you know what I I'm not
gonna be able to do it today because I
got to leave and go watch the baby but
tomorrow I'm gonna do my best to
remember to go back in I had thought
that I pushed that repo to github
evidently I didn't so I will definitely
do that at this week some point thank
you for bringing that up harsh it really
really sorry about that I just totally
thought that I had done it already let's
see I'd it's a stop coating on free code
Kent months back because of my exams and
now I don't know where to start from
I was a challenge to 58 and now I've
forgotten half the things at it I the
new curriculum is going to come out soon
I think sometime this month so maybe if
you want to just wait till that comes
out and then start from the beginning
again there might be a lot of new stuff
that's what I would do if I was thinking
about starting right now I would wait a
week or two to see if the new curriculum
was going to come out and then maybe try
from there and if you really want to do
some things now you know you can go back
through and do some of the other
problems if you want just to you know
stay up on things but that new
curriculum should be coming out really
soon
a harsh it says it's 3:30 a.m. now I
have to sleep immediately otherwise mom
will scold me hard waking that late if
she's awake
are yeah for sure go to sleep I do
not want you to get in trouble with your
mom I'll do my best to keep my streams
earlier in the day for you
all right so I really have to go now or
my wife is going to be upset with me so
thank you so much everyone this was a
great stream really great discussion and
questions I'm gonna try to do another
shrink tomorrow a little earlier in the
day for all of you over in in India I
know it was really late for you watching
and that we have quite a few people from
India that watch and from that time zone
so it'll be earlier tomorrow
but until then have a great day